this is hip lacrosse in the middle of a
new forest in southwest England I
couldn't find any official statistics
for the most dangerous crossroads in
Britain but this is certainly a
contender because even though it's quiet
and rural here there's not much traffic
there's an average of two incidents a
year here two cyclists have died in the
last ten years in near identical crashes
both times
a driver failed to stop and hit a
cyclist who had right-of-way on the main
road but the visibility is excellent
here it's well signed actually really
really well signed now I'm here it's
it's obvious there's a lot of road
markings for such a rural Junction but
people keep getting hurt here so why is
it so bad for the research here I am
indebted to someone called bez that's
the only name I could find I couldn't
track them down
they didn't reply to messages but bears
wrote the definitive article on why this
place is such a disaster let's say
there's a driver approaching on the side
road at around 40 miles an hour they're
not slowing down because they're
reckless and they can see the main road
is clear here's their view the cyclists
until the very last second was exactly
in the blind spot caused by the driver's
door pillar the drive isn't slowed down
for the stop sign which would have shown
the cyclists they didn't move their head
which would have shown the cyclist the
screen involved doesn't have to be some
magic bag number because of the angle of
these roads for every possible speed
that a reckless driver might be
travelling at there is a reasonable
speed for a cyclist on the main road
that will keep them right in that blind
spot all the way but why won't the
cyclist see the car they have a right of
way yes but surely they notice that the
cars not slowing down
well if these two roads were crossing at
right angles to each other yeah they
would see them I'd don't get me wrong
the driver would still be reckless but
at least the cyclist would notice and be
able to take your vase of action but
these roads aren't at right angles
there's one other subtle thing here in
this situation the car is approaching
from behind the cyclist the cyclist
won't see it until it's too late and
even if they do when both car and
bicycle slam on their brakes simple
simulations don't work anymore because
it's not up to trigonometry at that
point
it's up to human reactions and how both
of them try to avoid the collision this
Junction is at the worst possible angle
and it happened by accident you can see
on old maps that this was just the angle
at which two paths happen to intersect
and those were the paths that happened
to become roads over time this wouldn't
be built nowadays but at some point in
the early 20th century before it was
possible to travel by road at these
sorts of speeds this was a reasonable
Junction the local council has made some
changes not only the paint but you can
see on Google Street View that the signs
here used to be give why not stop stop
signs are really rare and rittany
they're only meant to use and
exceptional circumstances like this and
almost everyone rolls through them
anyway then they're clearly not working
because people keep getting hurt so why
hasn't it been redesigned speed bumps or
a chicane on the approach would solve
the problem but it's not legal to have
those unless you also have street
lighting which would mean laying miles
of new electrical cable enormous expense
that's assuming you get around all the
regulations that define this area as a
conservation area and the objections
from the locals about putting bright
lighting in a place famed for its dark
skies same problem with a traffic light
the best solution is to stagger the
crossing to curve the two side roads so
they don't meet each other but they meet
the main road at right angles force the
drivers to slow down but again
conservation area conservative locals
and a budget estimated at around a
hundred thousand pounds the cheapest and
easiest way to solve it of course would
be for drivers to stop at the stop sign
but road safety and anyone safety
shouldn't require faith in human nature
thank you do bears whoever you are
the research for this video started with
that article so I put a link in the
description please do go and read it
you